Quién es el impostor el impostor del 1
al 10 qué tan gay se siente ocho también
diría 8 diría que 9 o 10 un siete pasó
un siete porque me gustan ambos tengo
una relación poliamorosa Ahora entiendo
esta es mi primera relación después de
dos años Así que estoy más abierto a que
haya más variedad de la dinámica por eso
diría no estás respondiendo mujeres me
gustan más las mujeres por eso el 7 de
acuerdo cuando Travis me hizo preguntas
fue demasiado directo y no dejó que me
explicara bien su voz era nerviosa
cuando hablaba y creo que le daba muchas
vueltas a todas las respuestas Pero cuál
es tu orientación sexual lo siento te
interrumpir mientras hablabas soy
bisexual y entiendo Cuando
aproximadamente
descubrieron su sexualidad a mí me
criaron como un Mormón y tuve una
relación secreta con un amigo de la
universidad Luego de eso ya no podía
negarlo y acepté que era
gay cuando tenía 18 experimenté con una
chica y muchas cosas de mi vida cobraron
sentido
[Risas]
por supuesto bien por ti Travis fue muy
directo y no decía mucho eso me hizo
sospechar un poco salí del clóset a los
14 pero no soy gay pura tuve una fase
heterosexual me identifico Como
polisexual algunos géneros pero no todos
Odio a los hombres y género Así que
soy Aunque actualmente ya no me
identifico
Sí empecé a experimentar más en la
universidad Porque crecí en Ohio y vengo
de una familia y muy tradicional mantuve
el secreto por un tiempo hasta que me
mudé y empecé a vivir en California
donde todos tienen una mente más abierta
que en otras ciudades
bienvenidos
Y puede que sea no binario pero eso no
significa que sea
Travis está jugando a atacarnos a todos
y en realidad no da ningún detalle
[Música]
hay empate entre tres
el empate es entre netia debes y Travis
boquiabierto les daré 30 segundos a cada
uno para defender su caso y luego
volveremos a votar mi tía eres la
primera eliminarme sería muy homofóbico
Espero que lo entiendan soy muy femenina
y sé que mi ropa puede hacerlos pensar
que no soy gay pero es mi manera de
reafirmar mi Género me gusta presentarme
de una forma muy femenina es mi manera
de ser gay y no masculina o algo así
entienden podría nombrar algunos sitios
populares empezaré con Bitches También
conozco rocos y suelo ir a Javi con
frecuencia conoció a mi pareja cuando
fui a mickeys fue un día muy especial
que más
hamburgers es muy bueno no creen
ninguno solo tuvo sentido nombró un
montón de Clubes gays claro fue terrible
no se defendió bien debió hablar de lo
mucho que le gusta el pene No lo sé todo
estoy casado con un hombre Yo no sé si
eso los convence siempre he sido cuir
tengo un tatuaje de Winnie Pooh y otro
de Totoro que más quieren yo no podría
ser
nombres de muchos clubes gays no
significan nada
Lo siento
he jugado amigo
no quería que me eliminaran me hubiese
gustado hablar más con ellos todos
ustedes se identifican como queer o
tienen otra etiqueta
Cómo se sienten me siento me sentía muy
cómoda diciendo bisexual pero mi primera
pareja me dijo hace poco que es mujer
transgénero y mi pareja actual es un
hombre transgénero por eso siento que la
etiqueta bisexual me hace sentir muy
limitada actualmente a veces cambia eso
me refiero no fue Sino hasta mis 30 que
descubrí que había otro lado de mí al
que le podía Poner un nombre específico
ahora ahora me identifico como queer y
me siento mejor
igual Sí estoy de acuerdo a medida que
salía con más hombres empecé a decir que
era gay porque era más fácil me di
cuenta hace poco que Es un término
rígido mientras que la sexualidad es
fluida si bien me identifique como gay
por mucho tiempo me he dado cuenta
también que me atraen las mujeres y las
personas tranquilos y las mujeres son
hermosas
identificarme como lesbiana después de
muchos años de huirle a las etiquetas
porque no me gustaba la idea de
encasillarme pero ahora que sé que soy
huir siento que descubrí mi comunidad
entiendo que algunos crean que las
etiquetas son estudios pueden ser
liberadoras y hacerte sentir mejor todo
depende de cómo te sientes
no hablo mucho desde el principio supe
que era gay pero siento que Elizabeth
demostró más confianza cuando habló de
su identidad
no
está bien está bien
descuidense no entiendo
Gracias
sabía que pasaría no hable mucho si
creen que el impostor sigue con ustedes
si quieren seguir jugando levanten la
mano
creo que ya lo eliminamos
sí seguro sí estoy segura la votación ya
terminó no quiero decir algo que
arriesgue la Victoria no hay más
votaciones
un poco de ti porque tienes las
perforaciones típicas entiende que era
una trampa de producción entiendo tiene
sentido Gracias
sentí que tenías muchas vibras gay
demasiado también
ese problema en mi última relación de
los caballos lo siento
eso fue horrible qué horroroso cielos
basta dijiste que Elizabeth era amante
de los caballos
No sé lo siento
[Música]
eso fue ofensivo soy gay todos
escucharon
olviden lo que él dijo cuando llegué al
set era la única con medias altas por
eso me las quité luego después me dije a
mí misma al menos tengo zapatos de
lesbiana nunca pensé que dirían que
parezco granjera quiero confirmar que
están seguros estamos seguros estamos
muy bien
si la luz que se enciende es roja
significa que el impostor sigue con
ustedes y Por ende perdieron
si la luz es verde significa que lo
eliminaron y que ganaron
[Música]
[Risas]
ahora el impostor se revelará a la
cuenta de tres uno
dos tres sí
espera en verdad eres No binario no te
identificas
qué parte era mentira no mucho sí soy de
Ohio y tengo una relación poliamorosa
solo inventé no hay otro hombre él no
existe el resto es real tu relación
no hay ningún hombre dos chicas son solo
dos chicas ambas son bisexuales
muy bien
no era obvio
si tienes dudas sobre tu identidad date
tiempo para explorar y no saber que te
gusta por un tiempo hace un año perdí a
un amigo cercano era una persona
indefinida joven Yo solo quiero decirle
a los jóvenes indefinidos que todo
mejora llegarán a un punto de sus vidas
cuando se sientan cómodos dentro de esta
comunidad hermosa si se sienten que ir
la comunidad Los aceptará de inmediato
formarán parte sin problema tómense su
tiempo
descubranse a sí mismos Y si son queer
Felicidades somos fantásticos es una
compensación
lo logramos ganamos somos geniales